The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
EARLL MURMAN: So
let's just take stock
a little bit on why we're
going to do this next module.
Did you guys have some troubles
with supply chain management
in your factories on this
last round of simulation?
AUDIENCE: We did.
EARLL MURMAN: We did.
And how about the
suppliers down there?
Did you have a lot of
visibility of what was going on
with your customers?
AUDIENCE: For all I know,
they're building houses.
EARLL MURMAN: They're
building houses.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: And not very well.
EARLL MURMAN: And we
heard yesterday from Jeff
at Gorton's, about how
critical his supply
chain was in the
transformation of Gorton's
to a lean enterprise.
And we heard also, a little bit
at Aspect Medical about supply
chain.
So supply chain is a
really critical area
of a lean transformation.
And here's just a quote,
that 7% of the companies
today are effectively
managing their supply chain.
Now, that's a little
bit out of date.
It's 2003.
But only 7%.
But they're 73% more profitable
than the other manufacturers.
So who are some of the companies
you think about, you might
think about, that are
well-known for good supply chain
management?
AUDIENCE: Dell.
EARLL MURMAN: Dell.
AUDIENCE: Walmart.
EARLL MURMAN: Walmart.
AUDIENCE: UPS.
AUDIENCE: Toyota.
EARLL MURMAN: UPS,
Toyota, OK, exactly.
OK, so here's our
objectives for this module.
At the end of this
module, you'll
be able to recognize the
importance of suppliers
in the enterprise.
I think you probably know
that, going into the module.
We're going to talk about
the four key attributes
of a lean supply chain.
One of them is aligning the
design, the product design,
or whatever your area is
with the supply chain.
There needs to be
an alignment there.
One is having the suppliers
participate in your material
flow.
I saw someone for
the supplier table
coming up here,
delivering parts.
That's participation in this
material flow; Having them
actually involved in the
design and development
of your product; and then
the information flow.
And so then, also,
most organizations
have a legacy supply chain
that they have to transform.
Aspect Medical was lucky.
It was a startup.
But we heard from
Jeff, for example.
The company's been in--
Jeff, 1889?
AUDIENCE: 1849.
EARLL MURMAN: 1849--
OK, they had a legacy supply
chain they had to deal with.
This picture
diagrammatically shows
how suppliers interact with
both the product development
and production.
So remember, the customer is the
one that specifies the value.
And then the role of
product development,
or engineering,
which Annalisa is
going to talk about
this afternoon,
is really to develop a
design which, when produced,
meets those customer
expectations.
OK?
And one of the things that
happens in a lean supply chain
is to get those
suppliers involved early,
not think of them
as something you
add on at the end
of your design,
but to get them working
with you during the design.
And in the aerospace area,
typically, 60% to 80%
of the product value,
that is, the dollar
value of the product, is
outsourced to the suppliers.
And now, we saw that
yesterday at Aspect Medical.
They didn't give us the
numbers, I don't believe,
but they don't make anything.
They assemble things.
OK?
John Coolidge said that
they're a final assembler.
So a lot of the value
of that product,
they buy from suppliers.
So suppliers are absolutely
critical to their success.
Then, when it gets
to production--
and Annalisa is
going to talk more
about the interaction of product
development and production,
where the value is
created and delivered back
to the customers-- you
want to have your suppliers
as partners.
So you have to think
of the suppliers
as part of your enterprise.
And we call that the
extended enterprise.
So today, you want to
think about those guys
at the back table as
part of your enterprise.
They're not somebody you just
send orders to and get parts
from.
OK, now what does a
supply chain look like?
Well, here is a generic
picture, starting
with the end user, customer,
the prime, all the way
down to some raw
material supplier.
And usually, these are
in tiers-- first tier,
second tier, and
third tier suppliers.
And as you move down
the supply chain,
each tier represents
a smaller proportion
of the mean business.
But they're very critical.
So let's just get
a little example.
We have an interesting group
here, a very diverse group.
So let me call on some people.
And tell us a little
bit about where
you fit in in your supply chain
and how far up and down you
can see.
So Tam, you're with Intel.
OK, where in Intel
do you fit in this?
Are you a prime, or are
you a supplier to a prime?
AUDIENCE: I'm not really sure.
I worked at [INAUDIBLE].
So I would say I [INAUDIBLE]
the facility that's prior to
and lean part of [INAUDIBLE].
EARLL MURMAN: OK, so a couple of
things here-- first of all, Tam
is in product development,
and he doesn't
know what his supply chain is.
Right?
OK?
Is that what I hear?
Who's your end customer?
Do you know?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EARLL MURMAN: OK, so that's
not the end customer.
But you have a manufacturing--
that's your customer,
is the manufacturing facility.
And what are they making?
AUDIENCE: Powder products.
EARLL MURMAN: A product--
AUDIENCE: Or end products.
EARLL MURMAN: And
are they then selling
that to Hewlett-Packard,
or somebody?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
And so they go to some
customer from Intel.
And then eventually, some
end user, like Donna?
AUDIENCE: Lynn.
EARLL MURMAN: Sorry.
Lynn-- she's using her computer.
She's the end user.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
EARLL MURMAN: OK, so
let's pick a different.
Luis-- Luis, you're
with the US Air Force.
AUDIENCE: Yes, sir.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
Now where are you in
this supply chain here?
AUDIENCE: Well,
we're a developer.
So we would be a customer.
EARLL MURMAN: You'd
be a customer.
OK.
And who might be the end
user of what you develop?
AUDIENCE: The Space Wing,
the 45th Space Wing.
EARLL MURMAN: Oh,
the Space Wing.
AUDIENCE: The 45th Space Wing.
EARLL MURMAN: OK, Space Wing.
OK.
And sitting where you sit
as a customer, how far
down the supply chain do
you interact with people?
AUDIENCE: Not very far down,
because we have a contractor
that does all that for us.
EARLL MURMAN: OK, so
your contractor's is
Lockheed or Northrop Grumman?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EARLL MURMAN: OK, so you
interact with a contractor, who
interacts with the suppliers.
OK.
Now Carlos, you're with Cargo?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
EARLL MURMAN: OK,
and in Mexico, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
EARLL MURMAN: OK, so do
you do food products?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
EARLL MURMAN: OK, so where would
you be in this supply chain?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] are
on the prime manufacturers
[INAUDIBLE].
EARLL MURMAN: OK,
so you're the prime.
And who might be your customers?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EARLL MURMAN: Huh?
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
And then, how far
down the supply chain
do you [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: We're the last,
the last [INAUDIBLE]..
EARLL MURMAN: You
see all the way
down the supply
chain [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EARLL MURMAN: OK, I'd like
to call one more group here.
And I don't know
much about it at all,
someone from the
Veteran's Administration.
So Doug?
Yeah, you're working with
health care and stuff like that.
AUDIENCE: Yes, I'm
basically at the end user.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: I work in
the lab department.
EARLL MURMAN: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
actually a customer.
And I provide results
to the physicians.
And I interact with
the [INAUDIBLE]..
EARLL MURMAN: OK, cool.
OK.
So you can see that these
are just different examples
of supply chain.
Now, one of the
things that comes out
a little bit in
this little exercise
we did, but is really
a very true thing,
is that most people in
a non-lean supply chain
don't have much visibility up
or downstream in that supply
chain.
And so what they get
is what we call-- they
get the orders over the wall.
So you might give an
order for reagents,
and they don't even
know it's going
to come until, all of a
sudden, it arrives, if it's
a non-lean supply chain.
So there's a lack of visibility.
If you're in the supply chain,
there's not much visibility
upstream or downstream,
what's happening,
until all of a sudden, you
get something, a request,
and you have to react to it.
And that's kind of what you have
at the back of the table there.
You don't have much visibility
of what's happening up here.
And so that means you're
in a very response mode.
OK.
So now let's do a
little exercise.
Here are some attributes
of supply chains.
And what we want you to do is
gather around your easel charts
and discuss these a little bit.
And write down, which
of these attributes
do you identify with what you
might think as a lean supply
chain, realizing we haven't
really covered that topic yet?
But this is part of how
we're going to go about it.
And talk a little bit
about what you think
might be the top three
priorities for a lean supply
chain.
So let's just say,
for example, you
picked all these as representing
a lean supply chain and not
those.
Which of these are the
three most important,
do you think, to have
a lean supply chain?
So let's spend about
10 minutes doing that,
around your easel charts.
And then we're going to see what
we collectively come up with,
a lean supply chain.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Should we
invite our suppliers now?
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah, you
can invite your suppliers
if you'd like.
Sure.
[LAUGHTER]
That sounds like
a good practice.
OK.
So let's see.
Let me call on
the table up here,
table in the northeast
corner, northwest
corner of the building.
What are your top
characteristics
of a lean supply chain?
And why did you pick them?
Someone want to give
us that briefing?
AUDIENCE: Well, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: The
first one we picked
was responsive and agile.
We need our supplier to give
us what we need, when we need,
and in a timely
manner, so that we
can make those [INAUDIBLE]
quota enterprise approach,
so the end to end.
So just knowing what the
other processes means we
don't end up with
national [INAUDIBLE]..
And then we had [INAUDIBLE] with
collaboration and continuous
[INAUDIBLE] activities with
the supplier customers-- again,
just partnering
with our suppliers
and not just [INAUDIBLE].
EARLL MURMAN: Good.
OK.
Good choices, good choice
and good priorities.
How about back here?
AUDIENCE: We did collaboration
and supplier commitment
with long-term relationship,
which probably go together.
Because if you're going to
have a long-term relationship,
you're going to work together.
EARLL MURMAN: Good rationale.
AUDIENCE: Visibility of demand,
so you can see what's coming;
and just continually improving.
EARLL MURMAN:
Continuous improvement--
OK, good.
And you had some others up there
that you put a lower priority.
AUDIENCE: I mean, the
enterprise approach
made sense, of looking
at the whole envelope.
And build to order, so
that your activities
are driven by the customer
requests and the responses.
EARLL MURMAN: OK, good.
OK, let's take one more.
And then how about up here
with all the colored dots.
It looks to me like you
did the multi-voting.
That's good.
[LAUGHTER]
Someone want to
tell us about that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we [INAUDIBLE].
We say that this
customer is just good.
When we came to the queue that
[INAUDIBLE] continuous grouping
was [INAUDIBLE].
Together, it's collaboration
and the holistic enterprise
approach.
EARLL MURMAN: OK, so we're
seeing some commonality here.
Let's see, let me just
look at the others.
I see the same things on
the remaining ones here.
OK, so I think you
guys got pretty much--
very good.
You're already beginning to
identify what a lean supply
chain is, before you even have
heard about it, so to speak,
which is part of the
purpose of this exercise.
Another thing we see is the
priorities are a little bit
different between tables.
And this reflects what
happens in the real world,
is that different organizations
might have different priorities
as to what they think is most
important in a particular time
with their supply chain,
for whatever reason
you picked at your table.
But maybe they're
having difficulty
with collaboration,
or something,
so collaboration is going
to be more important
right now in
getting their supply
chain lean than something else.
The only thing I would add--
that the build to order,
I understand why you put
it there as a response
to the customer.
But that's actually a way of
describing a non-lean supply
chain, where you
ship orders, and they
send you back materials.
But you don't really
engage them at all
in the design of the product.
You just send them an order,
and they send it back--
kind of send me the blueprint
and send me back the parts,
and let's negotiate on
price, type of thing.
So the ones that are identified
here as a lean supply chain are
collaboration-- you got
that; responsive and agile--
you got that; based on
product characteristics--
I don't think we had
anybody come up on that,
but we're going to talk
about that in a minute;
enterprise approach;
a commitment
to a long-term relationship;
a visibility of demand,
which was getting over
that brick wall barrier;
and the continuous improvement.
So we're on the same page.
OK, so let's move on now to the
second main learning objective.
So you can now recognize the
attributes of a lean supply
chain--
I mean, the main attributes.
Here are the four we're
going to talk about.
And the first one is
alignment with the product
characteristics.
And this may be a
little bit theoretical,
but you can think
of it, in theory,
of two ends of the extremes.
One is you have a push
system, where somebody builds
parts and sends them to you.
They build their parts,
thinking about some demand that
might be out there.
And then they're
ready to send them
when somebody makes an order.
And the other extreme would
be a pull supply chain,
where they don't build
anything until you ask them
for that, in some way respond
to the customer demand.
And in some sense,
supply chains are
a combination of push and pull.
These are theoretical concepts
at the end of a spectrum.
But a push supply chain might
be most prevalent in a commodity
area, where you're maybe still
in the economies of scale
mentality.
Let's build as many
as we can and ship
to the demand that comes.
In a mature environment, that
probably works pretty well.
OK.
So paperclips-- we're going to
use some paper clips tomorrow
on one of the exercises.
People making paper clips--
they kind of know about what
the demand is going to be.
It doesn't change that
rapidly, so they can maybe
do a push supply
chain type thing.
Where a pull supply chain, you
have some specialized part,
at the other extreme.
We're going to show you,
in a little bit, an example
from Lockheed Martin, where
one ship set a year of tubes
for an Atlas V
rocket, they don't
want to make those
tubes until they
know that the rocket's
about ready to be re-sent.
So the point is that your
product may be made up
of different components.
And the supply chains
that go with those
may be managed
somewhat differently.
One size doesn't fit all.
So that's what it means
to align your product--
your supply chain with the
product characteristics.
OK, supplier participation in
material flow and logistics--
just-in-time deliveries--
I think everybody's
pretty much familiar with
that, that that's really
an output of the Toyota
production system and all.
And of course, the
crucial thing is
that the parts have to
show up when needed,
because just-in-time parts go
right to the assembly line.
And so if they don't
show up when needed,
then everything
else gets impacted.
On the other hand, the advantage
is there's no inventory.
And if there are any issues that
come up on quality type things,
you can correct them right away.
OK, so just-in-time deliveries;
kitting for point-of-use--
we talked about that a
little bit yesterday.
And let's put that off, because
the next example shows that.
Vendor-managed inventory-- this
is where the inventory, instead
of being owned by the customer,
is taken care of by the vendor.
Let me give you an
example of that.
So JDAM is a Joint
Direct Attack Munition.
We have a picture of
it coming up later.
It's made in East St. Louis.
And one of the parts for
that is made in California.
I think it's a tail
cone, or something.
And when I went
through this plant
in East St. Louis,
Missouri, there's
a video camera on the
ceiling in the loading
dock, where they receive parts.
So what's that video camera for?
Well, the supplier
in California is
looking at what the inventory
is there in East St. Louis
and seeing when it's time
for them to ship more.
So they're managing the
inventory of that product.
And third party logistics--
this is, instead
of that organization shipping,
or the receiving organization
shipping, they
delegate that to FedEx.
And FedEx, they hire FedEx
to handle all the shipping.
And so UPS and FedEx and those
big companies, like Atlas Air--
do you guys do that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
we have [INAUDIBLE]..
EARLL MURMAN: Pull
their elements, yeah.
So there's a big business in
these third-party logistics.
So let's look at an example now.
And think about these
on this next example,
and how many of them do we see?
OK, so this is the Atlas V.
The Atlas V is a large launch
vehicle.
The Atlas V and the Delta IV
are the largest launch vehicles.
These are big rockets.
OK?
And they receive
tubes, when they
have to put together a rocket,
and what they call a ship set.
They call that a ship set.
And a ship set of
tubes cost $180,000.
And now, how do they come?
Well, in the old way, they
came as separate parts.
A ship set has 199 parts in it.
And they came all in
their own packing boxes,
separately, wrapped
up in foam, and stuff.
And you've got all this waste
and lots of stuff coming in.
That's the old way.
The new way is they
come in this kit.
And everything, all 199 parts,
with these five major tubes--
they have the
connectors and all--
come as a kit.
And they not only come
with the hardware,
but the tools to assemble them.
And usually, the
instructions that go with it
are right with that.
So there were some [INAUDIBLE]
cards yesterday about kitting.
And this is what
kitting is about.
OK?
And now, they make about one
or two of these rockets a year,
or a small number.
So they keep their
suppliers informed when
they're going to need that.
And all this is managed as one.
So they don't ship these until--
this is a pull system.
They don't ship
it until they know
that they're going to need it,
because it's an expensive thing
to have in inventory.
And all this 199 parts is one
record in their MRP system.
instead of 199 different parts
they're checking, following,
they follow one--
so the great reduction in costs,
handling costs, and carrying
costs in cycle time.
So some of those things we
saw on the previous slide--
kitting, vendor-managed
inventory, pull system,
you see in situations like this.
OK, let's now turn to
supplier involvement
in design and development.
And oh, by the way, this is a
little bit of a segue slide,
because this is this JDAM
munition I mentioned before.
And the JDAM part is it's
a retrofitted tailcone
on a otherwise dumb bomb.
And it turns into a smart bomb.
It has a receiver in it
and GPS system, and so on.
And all of this, by the
way, comes in a kit.
Here's what it looks like.
OK?
So that's a kitting.
But more importantly, here,
when the JDAM was developed,
it was done very uniquely.
This is an Air
Force procurement.
And when they formed
the proposal team
to bid on it, a
competitor proposal team,
they had McDonnell
Douglas, at that time,
and Lockheed bidding.
That proposal team actually
had the key suppliers on it.
And it also had an Air
Force representative
on the proposal team.
They were proposing
to the Air Force,
but there was an Air Force
representative on it.
The Air Force representative
was not on for business reasons.
The Air Force
representative was on so
that the designers understood
the requirements of the Air
Force.
So they understood
the requirements.
They had what they
call gold congruency.
All the members of
this team knew what
they were trying to achieve.
They were trying to achieve
the winning bid that satisfied
the Air Force customer needs.
OK?
That was what drove
all their decisions.
And so they understood what the
costs, the requirements were.
Now, what did they do?
They got the designers,
and the subcontractors
were involved in the design.
And this turned out,
that in the process,
the subcontractors had to
rearrange their expected work
share.
Some subcontractors gave up
a portion and others gained.
So actually, if you think about
it from a narrow point of view,
you're giving up some business,
so that you can gain some.
But they knew that that was
important to win the contract.
And so they
reallocated work share.
Specifically, they had some
partitioned electronics
on separate boards.
And they realized, that
if they integrated those
on the same board, they could
greatly reduce the costs,
and so on.
And the result was,
where they originally
thought this unit was going
to cost $68,000 per unit,
in the end, it cost
$15,000 per unit.
And Boeing now--
McDonnell Douglas
was bought by Boeing.
Boeing is making these things.
That's the plant
in East St. Louis.
And everybody's happy.
Boeing is making lots of money.
The Air Force is getting
lots of supplies.
But look how much
cost reduction they
had by getting those
designers involved
in the development,
subcontractors involved
in the development and design.
OK, then the fourth attribute
is the seamless flow
of information.
And this is a busy
picture, which
we don't want to read all.
But the point is that
we got here the system
integrator, the Aspect Medical.
And we have over
here the supplier.
And in a non-lean
supply chain, what
would happen is, over here, an
engineering of the supplier,
they may have a question.
They would go up to
their sales department.
That would come over
here to procurement.
It would come down
here to get answered--
lots of vertical
communication paths.
What you want in a
lean supply chain
is a lot of horizontal
communication paths.
And you need to align it with
the level of the organization.
So you would like engineers
talking with engineers.
Now, sometimes we give this
talk at a government procurement
audience.
They say, oh, that's illegal.
Can't do that.
It may be, but that
means it's also not lean.
OK?
Those things can be changed.
But you have to have
some clear guidelines
about what's
communicated, who has
responsibility to communicate.
But you want these
people on the phone
and on email contact,
sharing information,
to have a flexible,
responsive supplier.
OK, so we've got a lot
of information flow.
Common databases-- you want to
be accessing the same database.
You want to have members on the
same integrated product team.
We'll talk about that tomorrow.
You want to be exchanging
technical data at this level,
not going up and down, and
some other things here,
which we won't go into.
But clearly, that's
a different way
of doing business from
an environment where you
have a non-lean supply chain.
OK, another example of smooth
information flow is Exostar.
Exostar is a company,
an organization,
which manages the interactions
between major aerospace
companies and their suppliers.
So it's like a hub
in the supply chain.
They have 34,000
participants in this system.
And it's all electronic.
So suppose Boeing wants to buy
some kind of, say, actuators.
Instead of going to all
the actuator companies,
they go through Exostar, who
manages that transaction.
And it's all very paperless.
And it's just been
a huge savings.
And here are some results
from Rolls Royce, which
is one of the members,
some of the metrics
that go with their
participation in Exostar.
Instead of having several
thousand suppliers,
they deal with several
hundred; reduction
of cost of goods
purchased of up to 20%,
because of this integrated
supplier management;
system inventory
levels down 80%;
error reduction down,
because they're not manually
entering in a lot of
data; reduced cycle times
as much as 80%; basically,
elimination of paper;
and improved relations,
who have benefited
from this reduced
transaction costs.
OK, so now let's move to the
last topic of the module.
And that is, how do you improve
the existing supply chains?
Well, we already heard
from Jeff yesterday.
You work with your suppliers.
OK?
You look at your value stream.
You try to find out, who
are your critical suppliers?
You want to work with them.
So who's on the critical paths?
Where are the high-cost items or
the long-lead items, and so on?
And Jeff just couldn't
have said it better.
Yesterday, he said,
when they started
their lean transformation,
they went out
and let their suppliers
know that they
weren't dropping them.
They were just going to
deal with them differently.
OK?
If the supplier is ready to
become a lean organization--
now, they may not be ready yet.
They may not have
the right management,
or they may not be educated.
They might not have
taken a Lean Academy
and learned the
importance of this.
Then they've got to
do some prep work.
But if they're lean-ready,
then they can go out.
And the prime will actually
work with the supplier.
They'll go out, and they'll
run Kaizen events with them.
They might lend
them a lean expert
to be on site for a while.
They might invite them to
their training programs.
We taught one of these
Lean Academies at Raytheon,
up the road-- not Raytheon--
Textron Systems, up the road,
here in Wilmington, Delaware.
A couple of years ago, Hugh
and I and Jackie taught that.
And they invited their
suppliers to the class.
They had about five suppliers,
some from California,
some from Colorado.
They build their relationship.
They understand what the
value-stream mapping,
that value stream is.
They come up with their plans
to develop a lean strategy
in that organization.
And they have some mutual
workshops and Kaizen events
and a kind of a continuous
improvement cycle.
So this is the way
a lean organization
works with its suppliers.
It helps them.
It invests in them.
Actually, we have
some people here
from the Veterans
Administration.
Rockwell Collins,
which we've already
talked about in
this Lean Academy,
starting to see that
some of their major costs
were their health care
for their employees
in the Cedar Rapids area.
So they started working with
the Cedar Rapids hospitals
to help them become lean.
Because they knew,
in the long term,
it was going to benefit them.
And they loan their lean
experts to Mercy Hospital
in Cedar Rapids.
And they're doing gratings now.
OK, here's one example from
Boeing about Hicksville Machine
Works on Long Island and some
of the benefits that came out.
And these benefits that
Hicksville came from Boeing,
they're going to use
with other customers.
Boeing invested in it, and
they'll use other customers.
That's OK, because
everybody's going to win.
So those are
typical type things.
Now, as you do this, you start
treating your supply base
more strategically.
Instead of a supply base being
all the same, you're strategic.
So certain ones you have
strategic alliances with,
these might be really
critical partners.
For instance, Rockwell Collins
has a strategic alliance
with Boeing, because
they build flight decks.
Your suppliers--
you'll certify them,
so that-- say a gold
supplier is very reliable.
You might not do any
inspection on something that
comes in from a gold supplier.
It just goes directly
online, because you
know that they have their
processes under control,
and that they've inspected
it before it left,
and taken the quality
responsibility.
Where, someone who
is on probation
might be just the opposite.
You're not having good
performance from them,
so you have a lot
of quality control.
Then you might have your
people out in their--
they might be having troubles
with their production system.
And so you're sending help
out there to help them.
OK, strategically support--
important suppliers
might have, say, some
particular kind of materials,
some titanium, or something,
that maybe there's
only one supply for.
So that one, you want
to treat strategically.
These are the commodity items--
a core.
And then these are the
ones you get rid of.
They're just not performing.
So supply chain management
is a core competency
of a lean organization.
OK, where are we
going in the future?
The old approach is
the build-to-order.
The customer sends an
order to the prime.
The prime sends it
back to the customer.
The prime puts it down
to the subcontractor
or the subcontract--
so a lot of interfaces,
rigid interfaces,
lack of communication,
distrustful relationships.
The prime beats up
on their supplier--
get your costs down,
that type of thing.
Current lean is much
more collaborative
with sharing a lot
of information.
So you might invite
your suppliers in
and give them your sales
forecasts, your business plans.
That's very proprietary
information for most companies.
But if it's an
important supplier,
you want them to know
what the visibility is.
Emerging lean is
like with the JDAM,
where you actually form
almost like a company
for that project.
And you open up your
proprietary databases
for design and development.
And there's some examples
in our book about that.
OK, so wrap up--
suppliers are critical to
the lean enterprise success.
Supply chains need to be
understood and designed
to meet the needs
of the product.
Legacy supply chains
can be improved
through win-win customer
supplier teamwork.
And it's a core competency
of a lean organization.